so even something as simple as
scrambling an egg is essentially a
scientific manipulation of an ingredient
by exposure to get to both heat and
movement and incorporating an area
making it behave an egg behave in a in
the desired way it reminds me this is an
obscure analogy but it reminds me of
when medicine became modern it did so
because in part it looked to see what
sort of folk remedies existed around the
world and cultures oh you chew on this
bark and that gets rid of your headache
well what got rid of headache so you
find out what's in the bark right and
there's this molecule that becomes what
we today call aspirin and so you extract
the active ingredient right and then you
can exploit that to a great game and so
it seems to me if you knew exactly the
moment and why a sauteed onion becomes
sweet mm-hmm you can possibly hone in on
that and exploit that fact with other
foods and and that's what chefs are
doing some chefs are doing everyday I
have friends who are rotting all
varieties of things in some dark corner
of their cellar experimenting talking to
microbiologists from major universities
talking on late at night working with
them kitchens discussing you know the
wonders of fermentation what can you
ferment what can you what's going on in
me so how could I apply that to
something else a machine I love so much
of food is not about freshness it's
what's called that sweet spot the the
precise moment in its decay where it is
best sushi being the best example anyone
who goes and tells you that you know I
went to a sushi bar last night it was it
was the best a fish was so fresh I have
no understanding at all of sushi it's
not sushi is not about freshness at all
first of all even the best places
deliberately cure their fish by freezing
it so I'm out of sometimes out of
necessity to kill the critters others
because it makes it better but it's
almost never about the freshest fish
fresh fish is right out of the water is
still in rigor and it's often rubbery
and unpleasant and without much flavor
which is quite easy and Iceland they rot
it sometimes because you get more fun
you're looking for the perfect point in
the decay of the fish same with me
almost everything we eat and like cheese
meat fish they're all aged just wine so
it's really about decay and rot cheerful
is that's just I never knew
[Applause]
[Music]
you